hello everyone and welcome to a truly
remarkable game uh that will improve
your day at least tenfold and i'm not
even exaggerating it's from the 2014
dortmund sparcazan tournament where
fabiano caruana is facing former federal
world champion ruslan
the game comes as a suggestion from
malakal on twitter so thank you for that
it's a really a wonderful suggestion so
without uh dwelling too long on you know
anything but the moves let's check it
out so fabi with the white pieces opens
with e4 that we have e5 by panomario of
knight to f3 and knight to f6 going for
the uh petrov defense we have knight
captures on e5 grabbing that pawn and
now d6 chasing away the knight and then
we're going to recapture on e4
and now nowadays even knight captures on
f7 is uh possible a lot of strong
players are playing that but in the game
knight to f3 was played we have knight
captures on e4 so going for the
classical variation and knight to c3 now
challenging this knight knight captures
and the d captures and now okay white's
uh pawn structure is a little bit messed
up here but white has excellent
compensation he has very natural way of
developing his bishop pair all of the
lines are open and he can just castle to
safety very easily and it's very easy
for black to go wrong if he's not
careful for example you could play some
like bishop to g4 let's say h3 we chase
away the bishop bishop doesn't black
doesn't want to give up the bishop pair
plays bishop h5 we play queen to d5 we
attack the bishop the b7 pawn and now
black has nothing better other than to
give up the bishop fair and you've
already won the bishop pair without even
doing anything so you have to know a
little uh you know things like that but
okay in the game of course ponomario is
a very strong player he plays bishop to
e7 bishop to e3 by fabi and knight to c6
we have queen to d2 developing the queen
preparing castles queen side and bishop
to e6 sing okay but if you castle
queenside i'm gonna grab the pawn on a2
uh of course that's a joke as that is
not possible fabi just plays castle's
queen side and now grabbing the pawn uh
it does look um tempting but you can't
really do it if you go bishop captures
an a2 we're gonna first trap the bishop
of course we play on king to b2 we're
going to capture the bishop next
uh and if black plays some like a5 we're
going to attack the bishop a4 uh you're
gonna capture it pawn captures king
capture cs you've
eliminated the white's king's defenses
but there's nothing to attack the the
white king with
so yeah you're not going to have a a
a lot of fun playing this of course it's
possible i know some people that would
definitely play this and myself maybe
included but uh not for a strong player
like ponomariov so queen to d7
continuing development and now the
prophylactic king to b1 of course we
have bishop to f6 now the bishops are
very nicely placed attacking fabi's
queen side and h3 we have h6 by black
and now we have b3 and it is now as of
move 12 that this position has never
been reached a game and we have uh well
a unique game so to say
so how do you continue here well black
plays a6 it seems like a5 is something
you want to do you know you want to open
up
the white king's defenses but a4 pretty
much stops that and there's no further
attacking that uh white king so instead
we have a6 and now g4 by fabi we have
queen side castles and the bishop to g2
now fabi also placing his bishop pair
towards black's king so g5 and now
knight to d4 and this is now a
beautifully placed knight you do not
want this knight to remain here uh you
don't want to capture for nothing but
you know if uh if you don't have
anything better you have to capture it
because now we're just already
threatening to mess up black spawn
structure the bishop is also attacking
that knight so you kind of have to do it
but
you know white will undouble his pawns
but okay capturing is the best thing to
do here knight capture c captures and
now d5 black has to close the position
uh and now uh all
all four bishops are really
not doing all that much but the death
can change in an instant that's how
chess works so fabi tries to give his
dark square bishop this wonderful
diagonal by playing uh
f4 so f4 is played and now you can't
really ignore this because if f5 is
played then the bishop is trapped here
so your option is either to capture on
f4 or to play queen to e7 make some room
for the bishop and d7 uh maybe this
looks a bit uh passive so ponomari of
captures on f4 we have bishop captures
and now you could try something like
bishop g5 yes it's a pawn sacrifice but
it will eliminate white's a very strong
bishop uh whereas your bishop isn't
doing all that much but in the game we
have h5 trying to create some weaknesses
on the kings side now we have a triple
attack here on the g4 pawn and fabi just
advances it's the g5 with bishop to g7
and now rook d to e1 uh here you might
consider also a move like h4 but maybe
fabi i didn't want to allow black to go
for this immediate f6 so instead he goes
to rook d to e1 not rook h31 it seems
like this is a more natural move but you
have to keep an eye on that h3 pawn for
the moment so rook d to e1
and what do you play here uh well here
uh h4 of course we do not want to allow
white to push h4 uh and now you could go
for something like rook to e3 rook to c3
try and put pressure on black's
king here but if you do something like
this we can just move the king and if
rook to c3 rook to c8 so no worries for
black here so fabi goes bishop to e5
offers a trade of bishops and even
though it seems like you're giving up
your really awesome bishop for black's
bishop that's not doing all that much
it's not all that black and white
because if captures captures uh then
you have a wonderfully placed rook here
at some point you're gonna bring this
rook to e1 you're gonna put a lot of
pressure on the bishop here you're gonna
undermine it with g6 and that's uh
that's basically fabi's plan so of
course we have rook d to g8 uh here
ponomario says all right at some point
we're gonna trade i'm gonna put my
bishop on a queen on the eight and then
i'm gonna go after your g5 pawn so fabi
has to prevent this he plays queen to f4
first uh and now queen to d8 now putting
indirect pressure to this g5 pawn so
bishop to f1 now fabi's bishop is going
to assume a very different diagonal from
this one from this one it's not doing
all that much so what can you play here
you don't really gain anything by
capturing an e5 right away we're gonna
capture with the rook and the g5 pawn is
still defended so after this bishop to
f1 we have king to b8
this king on b8 looks even uglier than
on c8 because now he's actually on this
diagonal but the king wants to come to
a7 that's the point so bishop to d3
and now comes bishop back to c8 it's
always a target here like we said at
some point white will play g6 undermine
this bishop and then play some like
captures and then maybe rook captures on
e6 so of course black wants to move this
bishop
bishop to c8 and it will work very
nicely here as a defender of the queen
side pawns with king to b2 uh also a
nice safe move for fabi's king and now
uh you don't really have a way of
increasing the pressure if you play some
like rook to h5 to try and eliminate
this bishop and then go after the pawn
we can just play rook h the g1 as not
only the bishop is attacking the h3 pawn
but for the moment we don't really care
about this if you play bishop captures
on h3 now then queen captures an f7 and
well it's just a complete miss of a
position that black will not enjoy so
after king to b2 we have bishop captures
on e5 now
white has to react to this of course a
rook captures on e5 and it's a terrible
feeling when you have to trade just for
the sake of trading but there wasn't
really anything better and now rook to
g7 we have to defend this f7 pawn
we have a4 by fabi and a5 now by
ponomario not allowing this pawn to
advance any further at some point you
want to play king a7 b6 and we'll try to
get this bishop somewhere maybe on b7
maybe on a6 all depends on what fabi
plays so king to a2
uh and now king the a7 and okay the a5
pawn is weak the king is also occupying
the a file so queen back to d2 going
after this queen captures on a5 with
check
but now just king to b8 and now you if
you go for this pawn then aponomite
grabs this pawn obviously with the rook
uh so not something fabi is interested
in he repeats queen to f4 and ponomari
repeats king to a7 so fabi has to try
a different approach to the position but
it's not uh easily done as all of his
pieces are kind of ideally placed okay
maybe not this rook but this rook is
stuck here guarding the h3 pawn but if
you think like that you will never find
great moves and achieve great
masterpieces so here fabio plays rook h
the e1 he offers the h3 pawn which is uh
well not all that easy to do then you
allow black to have this beautiful pass
pawn and you better have something to
show for so here uh ponomative captures
the pawn he says thank you for uh
allowing me to have this past pawn and
now what does fabi do well rook the e7
seems like one uh good idea going after
the c7 pawn but then queen d6 blocks the
queen the queen here is undefended so
you don't really have time to go for the
pawn and well what what do you do here
that's the question so of course uh
that's not what he went for he played
rook to h1 now the bishop will move and
we're gonna capture this uh h4 pawn so
here bishop goes back to c8 we have rook
captures an h4 rook captures and the
queen captures an h4 so this is how fabi
tries to keep the position alive and uh
you know uh well he he's trying to make
some progress we have b6 by black uh
uh going for for
this uh maneuver that we discussed
bishop cannot come to a6 maybe you can
even trade off the light square bishops
uh but now comes queen to h6 the rook
here is undefended so we're using that
uh to bring the queen all the way to c6
so here rook to g8 and now queen to c6
and here uh you have to
find uh uh well a good move for black
there aren't many but for example bishop
to b7 definitely uh keeps the game alive
now uh the the queen is attacked the g5
pawn is attacked twice you kind of have
to play queen to f6 we're gonna trade
here and the white will always be better
this is a very advanced spawn you can't
really go after it with the rook the
bishop covers the g6 square so there's
no worries about that and rook to e7 is
coming you're gonna put pressure on this
pawn on this pawn this is a weak weak
pawn
so fabi will definitely have a lot of
pressure here so instead of that after
queen to c6 uh bishop to e6 was played
it seems like it's regarding everything
but now i don't even have to tell you to
pause the video uh but i will ask you to
pause the video here and try to find the
winning idea for fabi while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on paying attention
at least a little bit as this is what we
were discussing for the entire game and
to those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course g6 pawn to g6
uh undermines the bishop here and
there's really nothing black can do
about this uh it's a
really really
uh powerful move uh of course if the if
the pawn is captured then we just win a
free bishop black cannot allow this you
could play something like bishop to d7
but this uh only ends bad for black for
example queen captures on d5 okay you
don't lose the material here we're gonna
play f captures on g6 but now bishop p4
we're threatening checkmate and also if
the queen moves too far we're going to
win the bishop on d7 so queen to c8 to
try and keep an eye on everything now
we're going to play rook to e7 go after
the bishop and after let's say the rook
defense we're going to move the queen to
avoid any nasty discoveries and now
black is basically without a move you
can't move the bishop but we're going to
play rook captures on c7 so it's a
really really ugly position for
uh
for black to handle and there really
aren't uh any good moves the bishop here
is just a monster controlling these
squares the queen controls a6 uh we can
even just go after the pawn we can just
pick up the pawn so many possibilities
here white would win this easily
but like i said after this g6 move uh we
have rooked the g7 by ponomario uh and
now comes g captures on f7 bishop
captures on f7 and this is the position
that's been uh well sort of the theme of
discussion for many many years ever
since it was played it's actually a
forced mate in 16 but you guys will not
need all that many moves you only need
the first two so feel free to pause the
video and try to find these two
miraculous moves while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding the start
of this
incredible combination and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course rook to e7 a full rook
sacrifice that's hard to comprehend uh
if you don't really see the follow-up
after we sacrifice the rook so you don't
have a good option here rook captures
and c7 wins the game if you try to
defend it with sunlight kingdom bishop
a6 and there's no defense against
checkmate you have to give up the queen
just to prevent the checkmate so after
rook to e7 of course panama have
captured the queen but now comes the
move you had to see and that is bishop
to a6 if you've seen the thumbnail of
course this is much easier as you know
where the pieces should be but now how
do you defend it there there's no good
move queen to b7 will be checkmate and
you don't have a move here to prevent
this king captures on a6 was played but
luckily our pawn on a4 guards the b5
square if fabi saw this position when he
played pawn to a4 then well i don't know
how he lost to magnus in in the previous
world championship match but uh maybe
magnus is just that strong who knows but
here of course fabi played queen to a8
check and this is also now a checkmate
so this is just an outstanding game and
once again thank you lakel for
suggesting it to me i have not seen this
game before i started youtube uh after
2014 uh so this game eluded me but
luckily not for not forever so we're
gonna
show this one more time even in slow
motion look at this rook to e7
just an amazing amazing sacrifice queen
captures now bishop to a6 another
sacrifice and then queen tate checkmate
uh brilliant brilliant game by fabi
so i hope you guys don't think i
exaggerated with the title but this is
this is something
you know atal would pull off on
on his best today and this is you know
uh for my understanding of chess this is
performing a miracle
uh so yeah fabio also won the tournament
one and a half points ahead of everyone
else so there's also that so hope you
guys uh really enjoyed the game uh i
would like to thank shanti chaganti
mathias binte federico conte lefredo
zachary bell and mike pomeraning for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon uh continuing uh to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
hopefully as nice as this one and
checking up on everything else that's
happening in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day